Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambhodassa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So this evening I've chosen this topic of renunciation.
Now it's not a word we particularly love.
We don't fall for it, you know.
but uh you won't find a wisdom tradition that doesn't have some level of sensual restraint in its teachings i mean consider you know lent for chris for christians and ramadan for muslims and the hindu tradition and the jains of course uh all have some form of fasting as part of their practice yeah uh so now in you know in in the buddha dharma we all
has made this distinction between self-mortification and renunciation.
By self-mortification, we understand that the body is to blame.
So if we lost our tongues, we wouldn't have any greed.
And of course, the body himself went under such practices, nearly starving himself to death.
And he ended up by saying that that sort of practice was just adding more suffering to the already discontent of life.
uh but renunciation is the restraint of the senses right understanding that it's nothing to do with the body but our relationship to it so uh the path of renunciation uh that is a direct path through renunciation uh and of course you know you'll get monks and nuns who live way out in the in the in the jungle they're completely renouncing any contact with uh with the sensual life
only going into the village to get some alms but to understand this to understand the importance of renunciation we have to really go back to the roots of the Buddha's teaching and that always lies in this delusion of a self so what what do we mean by that well whatever you finish this sentence with I am
right whenever you finish that with that's what you're not and that's what we of course uh presume ourselves to be in fact the i in the i am is also part of that delusion so um it's the problem of this me always wanting to be happy uh now that's not so bad you know the buddha actually has a whole chapter in the dhammapada devoted to being happy you know a happy self
But it's just what we are seeking for our happiness, which is going to cause disappointment and eventually a bit of sorrow.
So that's easy to overcome when we keep reminding ourselves that everything, absolutely everything arises and passes away and does not repeat.
So you can't repeat the party that you had.
It just doesn't happen.
it's only going to cause suffering trying to do that and so when we become dependent on something the mobile or a person that we become dependent on then uh you know when when we lose it that's where the pain is yeah so um
what we have to find out is where does this self manifest and that's the point of desire that's the direct psychological indicator that the self is active but it's a certain type of desire there's a special word in Pali for it this tanha there are other words for desire but this specific desire is the one that leads to indulgence it's the one that leads us to attachment yeah
so it obviously includes all the physical senses such as food and sex but it's the sensual pleasures too you know like art nature human association all that all comes under the name of sensual it's right some people only think of sexual but it's not it's the total sense organ of the psychophysical organism right which includes the intellect yeah
all the stuff we learn the history science etc um all the stuff we talk about the politics say no more um and and the culture etc it's all the imagination the fantasy all that's part of the sensual life uh and uh and of course the pleasures and joys we get from work yeah
so everything we're doing everything we experience we always have to be careful that there is this little bit of tanha when it's making us happy and even in the practice when we enter into beautiful states of mind a bit of peacefulness a bit of joy and the uh and those concentration exercises that some of you might practice the absorptions uh you become attached to them yeah
so all this would be perfectly lovely except for the clinging so that's why we're practicing renunciation right it's a way of letting go of our cravings no matter how small they are so the importance of the camera is found in the eight phone noble path so the first of course is right understanding which is exactly what we're trying to do here
And the second one is to do with right intentions.
Sometimes it's translated as right thoughts, but intentions, I think, captures it better because it's the intentions that create the attitudes that then manifest in speech, in action and in our livelihoods.
So what are these right intentions?
The first one is renunciation.
The second one is non-ill will.
And the third one is harmlessness.
So how do we put this teaching into practice?
Well, we can start little, you know.
It's getting used to letting go of things.
I mean, those of you who've been on retreats, you know all about this really, but it's good just to remind ourselves that we ought to do it as a little daily practice also.
So for instance, if you find yourself snacking and grazing throughout the day, you know, at a particular time, say TV in the evening, you know,
and you you recognize it as unhealthy yeah so you make a decision stop it i'm going to stop it you see but then you have to remind yourself you have to bear the discomfort so every time the word toast comes to mind you see or biscuit yeah whatever comes to mind the alarm bell should go off yeah then we we repeat the reasons to ourselves why we're not going to you know fall for it we're going to renounce it and then reaffirm that determination yeah
now uh surprisingly these desires begin to really loosen up after two or three days and and and and they go and that and that and we regain our agency right we gain back our control over our appetites i mean that's what we're heading for with you know because generally generally speaking we're enslaved to these things you know as soon as they come up they come up as demands and they become as needs well they're not needs are they
uh but even so even when we've got through that uh discomfort and now we feel we've got our agency back you always have to be careful that little demon of the self you know the demon of desire it's only lying low we're not careful we will soon become an obedient servant again so we have to remind us that not until the delusive self has been completely extinguished will such unskillful desires cease you know
so now here we might make a little distinction between boredom and disinterest so remember that desires are excited by stimuli and they lose their intensity over time so that's when we get bored with something right and uh taking food for instance as our little object here so it's the same you can't keep eating the same biscuit you've got to look for something else we need variety
but given enough time however we go back to our favorite biscuit see that's how boredom works he gets fed up with something we seek something else and then we remember oh wait a minute what about my favorite biscuit and then you're back back to that disinterest is something different it's a spiritual quality it is exactly that we lose interest in something so we don't longer care about biscuits or what biscuits we have or even if there are any yeah
Yet there's still the enjoyment of biscuit if it comes our way.
So to quote an ancient Zen master, when asked to explain Buddha Dharma, his reply was, no preference.
No preference.
That's where we're aiming, right?
We're aiming to a point where we're not sticking onto anything.
At a mental level, it's views and opinions, you know,
It's the same sort of attitude that we apply, sort of renouncing this, I'm right and everybody else is wrong, or almost wrong, or not as right as I am.
So there's always a conceit that underlies these positions.
It doesn't matter what it is, religious, political, cultural and so on.
Now, it doesn't mean to say that we have to change our understanding.
It may be.
It may be fine.
But being open to others, allowing us to nuance our understanding.
And occasionally we might even change our opinion, especially today with all this polarisation.
And then there's the members of the human community, aware of climate crisis, of mindless consumption.
So we have a duty here to simplify our lifestyle.
How many pairs of shoes do we actually need?
When you're buying some clothing, do you actually need it?
And then we have to see that the culture is caught up.
We are caught up in this selfishness that's been generated by neoliberalism and consumerism.
And then we get the idea of giving something away.
In the very act of generosity, we're actually exercising renunciation.
And of course, it makes living a little lighter.
When it comes to personal relationships, you see, we possess other people.
So it manifests as control.
We manipulate.
We use anger, threats of abandonment, spiteful action.
Yeah, we hold grudges and nurse them.
We offer presents and promises to entice them.
And becoming aware of those little behaviors, you know, developing the skills of forgiveness,
Training ourselves to see the situation from the other person's point of view.
All that is the exercise of renunciation.
Then there's the news.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
You know,
trailing through the news every morning, every evening, during the day, you know, always onto it, finding out what's happened next with this constant daily messaging of war, Trumpian shocks, injustice and so on.
So it's no wonder that we can build up a sense of hopelessness, disempowerment.
Now we can undermine this by method, of course, but sometimes the best policy is just to stop listening, you know, to limit the input.
During my first 12 years as a monastic, I took very little interest in world affairs.
You know, for long times I was quite secluded.
And it took a while when I came, when I got back into ordinary daily life here to find out what was happening.
But I never felt I'd lost anything.
uh the buddha in the discourse on developing matter which we read at the end again advises us not to be too busy so again it's about decluttering our lives spending how are we spending our time what are we spending it on social media doing things always having to do something you know trying to get back to just being every so often being and doing
do we find ourselves in a sense of rush of anxiety even a sense of occasional overwhelm see then you have to prioritize right you have to let go let go of some engagements and of course when we do that we find ourselves being more relaxed and we meditate better and become more aware about this underlying turbulence in our hearts which is often fueling the over activity
So it's allowing that to exhaust itself and bring a sort of greater sense of calmness.
And it really is a wise thing to constantly remind ourselves that tranquility, calmness, tranquility is a factor of enlightenment, a factor of awakening.
Now, renunciation isn't the fullness of the spiritual life.
Such practice brings a sense of ease into our lives, but it brings with it clean energy.
Letting go of the demands of egoistic self is a relief.
It's not a deprivation.
The energy, the freedom we feel, seeks a different focus, and the focus is the other.
So we're social animals.
Everybody knows that.
We love people.
We love animals.
we love to help others some of our greatest joys is supporting others in their griefs in their joys but you have to always remember this little devil of self may sneak in and we find ourselves doing good in order to feel happy that's no good you see right danger lurks in the most heartfelt generosity
Luckily, it's enough just to acknowledge the skillful motivations and then to reaffirm the good intentions.
So we don't have to be hard on ourselves.
You know, a dash of humility is needed here.
Just acknowledge that the work on ourselves is yet to be done.
That's a comfort.
The Buddha warns us, you know, the path is gradual, very gradual in my experience anyway.
So, renunciation.
Well, it's important.
We need to reflect on our lives, see where we're sticking onto something, someone, some behavior, and just allow ourselves to let go for a while.
See, suffering gladly the pain of releasing the numbed cramp and enjoy a bit of peace.
I can only hope.
My words have been of some assistance that I have not caused confusion and that by your practice of renunciation you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.